and the government has added turkey and
poland and two or three caribbean
islands
bonaire saint uh eustatius and saba
from the travel corridor this week so
they've been removed this means if you
arrive from these destinations
uh from 4 00 a.m on saturday
uh you will have to self-isolate our
correspondent
is uh with us now so ashna what more do
you know about
that and also um give us an update on
the latest numbers
yeah sure mark so we've just heard in
the last few moments breaking as you
mentioned
those new uh travel restrictions being
introduced for those countries as you
mentioned there probably the biggest
shock i think is
possibly turkey on that list we weren't
expecting that but poland we
potentially were expecting that to
happen that's because uh
the cases there have been rising
consistently that announcement coming
from the transport secretary grant
shaps saying that if you're coming from
poland
turkey and those other islands in the
caribbean you will be required now to
self-isolate
for 14 days that is because all of those
countries have seen their seven
seven-day infection rates pass
20 per 100 000 people therefore it's
rising above the government's
deemed safe threshold and therefore
triggering these new quarantine
restrictions
as grant chaps has also introduced and
also mentioned for the first time is
people who do not comply with those
self-isolation rules
they can now be fined a maximum maximum
of 10
000 pounds if they um do not obey
those rules so it does mean that for uk
holiday makers
there will be a frantic scramble to try
and return home before 4 a.m
on saturday